if you have benign prostatic hyperplasia
or BPH your prostate gland is enlarged
the prostate is a walnut-sized gland in
men just beneath your bladder your
prostate gland surrounds your urethra
the tube through which urine and semen
exit your body your seminal vesicles and
prostate make fluid that combines with
sperm cells to create semen
during normal urination urine flows from
your bladder through the part of your
urethra inside your prostate then
through the rest of your urethra
to leave your body
for unknown reasons your prostate gland
may enlarge as you get older
if you have benign prostatic hyperplasia
your prostate may grow large enough to
narrow or block the part of your urethra
that runs through it as a result your
enlarged prostate may slow or block the
urine flow out of your body
when you urinate
the symptoms of benign prostatic
hyperplasia include frequent urination
or urge to urinate especially at night a
weak or interrupted urine stream and
straining to urinate
over time untreated benign prostatic
hyperplasia may cause the following
complications inability to urinate
damage to your bladder and kidneys
bladder infections bladder stones and
urine leakage called incontinence
if you have benign prostatic hyperplasia
with mild or no symptoms your doctor may
recommend watchful waiting which
includes getting your prostate checked
every year to make sure your symptoms or
health are not getting worse
if you have moderate symptoms that
bother you your doctor may recommend
medication such as alpha blockers alpha
blockers relax muscle tissue in the neck
of your bladder and in the urethra to
improve your urine flow
5-alpha reductase inhibitors may also
improve urine flow over several months
by reducing the size of your prostate
you may receive a combination therapy of
both types of drugs
if medication isn't relieving your
symptoms your doctor may recommend a
surgical procedure called trans urethral
resection of the prostate or Terp during
this procedure your surgeon will insert
an instrument called a cystoscope
through your urethra to reach your
prostate
then a wire tool called a Receptus cope
will be inserted through the cystoscope
to shave off tissue which will widen
your urethra other minimally invasive
variations on this type of procedure use
lasers microwaves radio waves or
electrical energy from tools inserted
through the cystoscope to remove some or
all of your prostate gland
if your prostate is very large your
doctor may recommend an open
prostatectomy procedure
in open prostatectomy your surgeon will
make an incision in your lower abdomen
after exposing your prostate your
surgeon will make an incision in its
outer capsule
next the tissue inside your prostate
will be removed
and the capsule incision will be closed
with sutures
finally your skin incision will be
closed with sutures or staples
you can't prevent benign prostatic
hyperplasia but the following lifestyle
changes can make your symptoms less
severe avoid medication that can make it
harder for you to urinate such as
antihistamines and decongestants stop
drinking fluids for a few hours before
bedtime avoid drinking alcohol or fluids
that contain caffeine try to empty your
bladder by double voiding to double void
urinate wait a few minutes and then try
to urinate again